[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Mit diesem Video läuten wir
die Weihnachts-/Winterzeit dieses Jahr ein.
Ich weiß, man sieht es nicht auf den ersten Blick,
aber ich bin gerade nicht zu Hause.
Ich bin gerade in Mannheim in unserem Shop.
Komm, Josh, machen wir eine Rundumdrehung.
[Musik]
Guckt einmal, alle fleißigen Helferlein!
Sagt mal alle Hallo!
>> ALLE: Hallo!
>> SALLY: Und ich würde jetzt sagen,
ich richte jetzt hier meine Zutaten,
die Mädels und Jungs fangen jetzt schon mal an zu dekorieren
und dann geht es los.
Dann gibt es was Leckeres.
>> MURAT: Ja, wir machen das immer vor Weihnachten.
Das ist
– einfach, wenn ihr nachher in den Laden
nach Mannheim reinkommt,
soll es weihnachtlich aussehen.
Die Leute sollen etwas lachen
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: und sich erfreuen.
>> SALLY: Ich habe eine Kutsche besorgt.
Kannst du dich dann als Weihnachtsmann verkleidet
da reinsetzen und jeden Tag Fotos machen?
>> MURAT: Ja. Also ich bin samstags immer da.
Ich habe eine Kutsche
und ihr könnt dann Fotos mit dem Weihnachtsmann machen,
also mit mir dann.
>> SALLY: Perfekt!
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Komm, los geht's.
>> MURAT: Also dann kochst du für das Team
>> SALLY: Oh! Entschuldigung.
>> MURAT: und wir tun alles umdekorieren.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SALLY & MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: Los geht's!
Ich hole Zutaten und ihr dekoriert ab.
>> MURAT: Ja.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Also ihr seht schon,
jetzt haben wir uns hier alle versammelt an einem Sonntag.
Denn unter der Woche,
unter dem Betrieb können wir das gar nicht machen.
Jetzt wird hier schön dekoriert.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Die Deko haben wir ja im Prinzip
alles schon sortiert.
Alles, was Herbst war und Sommer war, raus.
>> ELA: Warum
>> SALLY: Was?
>> ELA: hat der Papa so einen dicken Bauch?
>> MURAT: So.
>> SALLY: Vielleicht kann der den Weihnachtsmann spielen.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Ela, du bleibst heute hier!
>> ELA: Nein.
>> MURAT: Und Saban, wir zwei machen Team Blödsinn.
>> SALLY: Ja, Team Blödsinn, könnt ihr Team Sterne sein?
Weil ihr könnt doch alles hinhängen.
>> SABAN: Opa, du musst auf uns aufpassen.
>> MURAT: Opa, du musst helfen.
>> OPA: Ich passe auf auf euch zwei.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Kannst du aufteilen?
Okay. Und ich kümmere mich ganz kurz um das Brot,
damit das aufgehen kann.
Und dann helfe ich mit immer so zwischendurch.
Josh, das kriegen wir hin, oder?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Komm, das kriegen wir hin.
Okay.
>> OPA: Guck mal, der Stern da oben.
Du hattest gerade so einen Heiligenschein.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Also jetzt habe ich hier mal die Zutaten,
hier vorne schon alles für den Eintopf.
Aber ich werde jetzt zuerst mal
das Brot ohne Kneten vorbereiten.
Da gibt es bereits ein Rezept auf meinem Kanal.
Ich mache jetzt praktisch das Grundrezept.
Ich habe jetzt keinen Dattelsirup, nehme stattdessen Honig.
Hier habe ich noch einen Essig,
Hefe, Wasser,
Salz,
Dinkelmehl.
Und dann verfeinere ich das Ganze noch
mit Pinienkernen,
Röstzwiebeln
und getrockneten Tomaten.
Und die getrockneten Tomaten, die sind auch bereits
in so kleine, feine Streifen geschnitten.
Und im Prinzip heißt ja das Brot ohne Kneten,
weil man es eben nicht kneten muss.
Das heißt, alle Zutaten einfach verrühren.
Ich mache das jetzt so:
Ich gebe jetzt hier mal das Wasser rein.
>> SAMIRA: Hallo!
>> SALLY: Machst du gleich helfen?
>> SAMIRA: Oh ja! Kann ich rühren?
>> SALLY: Ja. Hier.
Ich brauche immer Hilfe.
Warte, warte! Erst in der Mitte rühren.
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Guck mal. Dann die Hefe so reinbröckeln.
Damit sich die Hefe kurz auflösen kann. Weißt du?
>> SAMIRA: Das ist ja lauwarmes Wasser, gell?
>> SALLY: Genau, lauwarm.
Dann Zucker,
also im Prinzip, Honig rein,
drei Esslöffel.
So. Das ist schon mal ganz praktisch so.
Dann Essig dazu.
Und jetzt kräftig rühren.
Und wenn sich alles verbunden hat,
gebe ich noch Salz dazu.
Das immer nicht direkt zur Hefe,
sondern eher zum fertigen Teig.
Denn Hefe und Salz vertragen sich nicht so gut,
genauso wie Hefe und Fett.
Soll ich weiterrühren?
Wird das anstrengend?
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Ich gebe jetzt noch ein bisschen Wasser dazu.
Denn ihr seht schon,
Dinkel verträgt ruhig ein bisschen mehr Wasser.
Geht es noch oder soll ich?
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Einfach so lange rühren,
bis sich alles gut verbunden hat.
Ich meine, das ist jetzt eine große Menge mit einem Kilo Mehl.
Bei einer kleineren Menge
geht das schon ein bisschen einfacher.
>> SAMIRA: Ein Kilo?!
>> SALLY: Hm.
Der Teig hat sich jetzt super verbunden.
Und ich nehme jetzt einfach für die Samira,
weil die gerne ohne alles hat,
ein bisschen was raus.
[Musik]
Und in den restlichen Teig geben wir jetzt die Restzutaten.
Und da könnt ihr einfach entscheiden,
was ihr gerne habt.
[Musik]
Dann wäre der Teig jetzt schon mal fertig.
Den gebe ich jetzt
– also entweder deckt ihr ihn jetzt ab
und lasst ihn zwei Stunden bei Raumtemperatur stehen
oder ihr gebt ihn in den Dampfbackofen
bei Gärstufe so ungefähr 30 bis 34°C.
Da geht es nämlich um die Hälfte schneller.
Also da brauche ich wirklich nur eine Stunde,
bis er sich verdoppelt.
Das machen wir kurz.
Und dann kümmere ich mich direkt um den Eintopf.
So.
Warte, zuerst das große.
Oh, die zwei gehen gut rein, hä?
So. Wassertank rein.
Und dann hier auf Dampf,
Gärstufe.
Ich mache dann meist so auf 34°C runter.
Und dann machen wir das Ganze auf eine Stunde.
[Musik]
Hier sind jetzt mal die Zutaten,
die ich für den Eintopf geplant habe.
Denn das Ganze soll ja so ein Wintereintopf werden,
schön sättigend, wärmend
und,
ja, einfach lecker.
Ich glaube, das wird lecker.
Der Eintopf ist jetzt mit Fleisch,
aber ihr könnt ihn natürlich auch ohne Fleisch zubereiten.
Dann ist er sogar vegan.
Aber, da bei uns der Murat mitisst
und für den Murat Fleisch alles ist,
gibt es natürlich einen fleischigen Eintopf.
Kaum sage ich "Fleisch", kommt er um die Ecke geschossen.
Der war gerade hinten an der Kasse. Ich schwöre es euch.
>> MURAT: Wir müssen uns beeilen!
Sonst können wir gleich Ostern dekorieren.
>> SALLY: Dann mach!
Ich habe jetzt hier 1,7 Kilo Rinderschmorbraten,
zwei Zwiebeln,
– ich nehme jetzt hier eine rote und eine weiße –
zwei Knoblauchzehen,
Porree,
etwa 1,2 Kilo Kartoffeln.
Hier habe ich jeweils 300 Gramm Pastinaken
und Petersilienwurzel,
600 Gramm Karotten,
eine Fenchelknolle,
Gemüsebrühe,
Rosmarin.
Hier habe ich Erbsen aus dem TK,
dann noch die Gewürze Salz,
Pfeffer,
Petersilie,
– nein, das ist Paprika –
Lorbeer
und einen Wirsing.
Wie komme ich auf Petersilie?!
Es ist Paprika edelsüß.
Genau.
Und die wichtigste Zutat, das Olivenöl, kommt gleich.
Das packen wir nämlich gerade noch aus.
Denn das Olivenöl ist endlich da!
Was ich jetzt machen werde:
Ich werde jetzt zuerst mal das ganze Gemüse
waschen, putzen, schälen.
Ja.
Das machen wir jetzt im Zeitraffer,
denn das dauert ansonsten zu lange.
[Musik]
>> BAHTIYAR: Eine Eillieferung für die Sally.
>> SALLY: Juhu!
Oh, yay!
>> BAHTIYAR: Achtung.
>> SALLY: Kriege ich Rainbow?
>> BAHTIYAR: Lass dich überraschen.
>> SALLY: Ja!
Oh, wie schön!
Mein Rainbow!
Oh, unser Olivenöl!
Mein Gott!
Also den Brief brauche ich jetzt nicht lesen.
Ich weiß ja, was der Murat für einen Unsinn geschrieben hat.
Oh, lecker!
Ich koche das erste Mal mit unserem Olivenöl
aus meiner Flasche.
Special Zutat.
Das Wurzelgemüse haben wir jetzt schon mal gewaschen
– also geschält und gewaschen.
Was ich jetzt hier mach beim Lauch,
das mache ich immer ganz gerne im Anschluss.
Da schneide ich unten die Wurzel weg.
Dann schneide ich da hinten diese
dunklen Blätter weg,
so das
Holzige außen.
Und weil Lauch gerne auch in der Mitte sehr, sehr sandig ist,
mache ich es da nämlich so,
dass ich den in Ringe schneide.
Und dann wasche ich den hier
einfach in so einer Salatschleuder.
Weil dann bekommt ihr wirklich
komplett alle Sandreste raus.
[Musik]
Als Nächstes mache ich es jetzt einfach so:
Ich werde jetzt erst mal das ganze Gemüse schneiden
und hier in eine Schüssel geben.
Dann ist das schon mal bereit.
Und dann später noch das Fleisch.
Das Fleisch schneide ich einfach zum Schluss.
Beim Fenchel
– den schneide ich jetzt einfach in Streifen.
[Musik]
Und ich habe mir gedacht, ich gebe noch zwei Äpfel mit rein.
Die bringen so eine leichte Süße mit rein.
Ich glaube, das passt echt gut.
[Musik]
Ich habe gerade gehört, unser Vegan-Volkan kommt auch.
Jetzt muss ich so einen Teil praktisch ohne Fleisch machen.
Deswegen schneide ich jetzt
auch erst mal das ganze Gemüse,
damit es nicht in Kontakt mit dem Fleisch kommt.
[Musik]
Und alles an Gemüse einfach grob würfeln,
so, wie ihr es gerne haben möchtet optisch.
Ich glaube, gewürfelt ist cool. Doch.
[Musik]
Josh, ich sage jetzt das, was ich immer sage.
Man hätte ja auch eine größere Schüssel nehmen können.
Yasemin, kannst du...
Oh, danke!
Du hast mich schon beobachtet, gell?
>> YASEMIN: Hm.
>> SALLY: Perfekt!
[Musik]
Und jetzt kann ich hier schon mal das Fleisch nehmen.
Wie gesagt, ich habe so einen Rinderschmorbraten.
Und das schneide ich jetzt auch ganz einfach in Würfelchen,
wie so ein Gulasch.
[Musik]
Was ich zum Fleisch noch sagen will:
Ganz wichtig ist, dass das zimmerwarm ist.
Das heißt, wirklich nicht direkt aus dem Kühlschrank holen,
sondern erst mal auf Raumtemperatur kommen lassen,
bevor ihr es anbratet.
Denn dann wird das Fleisch schön zart.
Wenn es nämlich ganz kalt ist
und dann in eine heiße Pfanne kommt
– da könnt ihr euch ja vorstellen,
das ist, wie wenn man aus der Sauna kommt
und dann in so eiskaltes Wasser springt.
Dann zieht man eher so zusammen.
Und dann wird das Fleisch nämlich auch sehr zäh.
Und daher wirklich schön
auf Raumtemperatur kommen lassen.
[Musik]
Premiere!
>> SAMIRA: Mama, mein Herzset ist dran.
>> SALLY: Ich nehme das hier mal ab.
Das könnt ihr schön an eure Kette
oder an eure
– an euer Armband hängen.
Ei, was ist denn heute mit meiner Stimme los?
So. Dann hier einen Gusseisentopf am besten nehmen
und ein bisschen Olivenöl rein.
Schön erwärmen auf mittelhoher Hitze.
Also mein Herd geht jetzt hier bis 9.
Der hat auch noch PowerBoost,
aber wenn ich mit Gusseisen arbeite
– das ist ja wirklich ein Material,
was Wärme gut speichert und auch gut wieder abgibt.
Das heißt, da müsst ihr nicht auf voller Pulle arbeiten,
sondern wirklich eher auf mittlerer Hitze,
mittelhoch.
Ich mache jetzt hier auf 8.
Ja.
Und dann wird das Fleisch portionsweise angebraten.
Das heißt, ich nehme immer eine kleine Portion,
brate die schön scharf an
und nehme sie dann wieder raus.
[Musik]
Die Zwischenzeit nutzen
und die Zwiebeln und Knoblauch würfeln.
[Musik]
Okay, Josh, ich gehe auf Stufe 7.
Ist das okay?
Das ist mittelhoch.
Und jetzt wirklich nur so viel Fleisch da reingeben,
bis der Boden bedeckt ist.
Nicht zu viel auf einmal.
Denn, wenn ihr zu viel reingebt,
dann kühlt der Topf
oder die Pfanne kühlt dann schnell ab
und dann schmort es und brät eben nicht an.
Und ich will ja diese Röstaromen.
Schön scharf anbraten und dann rausnehmen.
Ich glaube, ich schalte es sogar ein bisschen höher.
Das müsst ihr so ein bisschen individuell
von eurem Herd abhängig machen.
[Musik]
Guck mal, wie lecker das schon aussieht.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Also ich sage es euch,
Gusseisen, das ist
– wenn ihr noch nie damit gekocht habt,
es ist wirklich ein komplett anderer Geschmack.
Guck mal allein jetzt schon das Fleisch an.
Das ist nur angebraten.
Ich nehme jetzt noch mal Olivenöl.
Dann hier die Zwiebel- und Knoblauchwürfel.
Ein bisschen lasse ich übrig, wie gesagt, für Volkan.
Der kommt ja auch noch.
Das heißt, der kriegt dann im kleinen Murat-Topf
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: kriegt der seine vegane Portion.
>> MURAT: Wobei der Murat-Topf,
der reicht ja auch für zwei, drei Leute, gell?
>> SALLY: Ja, auf jeden Fall.
[Musik]
Nach dem Anbraten dann
mit der Gemüsebrühe ablöschen.
Ihr könnt auch eine Fleischbrühe gerne nehmen.
Dann auf jeden Fall würzen.
Ich nehme jetzt mal
Paprikapulver in Edelsüß,
Lorbeerblätter
und Salz und Pfeffer.
Statt Gemüsebrühe könnt ihr auch einen Rotwein benutzen.
[Musik]
Und noch ein bisschen Rosmarin.
Jetzt lass ich das mal kurz aufkochen, verrühre alles gut
und dann das Fleisch wieder dazu samt Saft.
[Musik]
So. Und jetzt habt ihr nämlich schon mal
den Großteil der Arbeit erledigt.
Da kommt jetzt der Deckel drauf
und das Ganze wandert einfach in den Backofen
bei 160°C für ungefähr zwei Stunden.
Dann wird es nämlich schön zart.
Und den Volkan-Eintopf
mache ich jetzt auch gleich noch fertig.
>> MURAT: Soll ich dir so Fingerdings holen?
>> SALLY: Oh, bitte.
>> MURAT: Kurz holen?
>> SALLY: Ich habe hier hinten in der Schublade.
>> MURAT: Wo?
>> SALLY: Die müsste ich...
Hier.
>> MURAT: Also ich kenne mich weder daheim
in der Küche aus noch hier.
Für mich ist es kein Unterschied.
So.
>> SALLY: Machst du mir den Backofen auf?
>> MURAT: Ja. Den?
Nee.
>> SALLY: Nee, den links.
>> MURAT: Den hier?
>> SALLY: So. Den Fingerschutz nicht mit rein.
>> MURAT: Perfekt.
>> SALLY: So mache ich ihn glücklich.
[Musik]
Hier habe ich jetzt noch den Wirsing.
Und Wirsing ist ja schon so ein Wintergemüse,
so ein Winterkohl.
Und der ist wirklich supergesund.
Man kann ganz viel damit machen,
entweder einen Eintopf,
ihr könnt Krautwickel auch daraus machen.
Also da gibt es wirklich ganz, ganz viele tolle Rezepte.
Vor allem finde ich die Farbe auch so genial.
Und Wirsing ist ultragesund!
Da ist Vitamin E mit drin, Vitamin B6.
Ihr habt Folsäure. Ihr habt Eisen mit dabei.
Also Wirsing sollte schon vor allem im Winter
auf eurem Speiseplan stehen.
Ich nehme jetzt hier mal die äußersten Blätter ab.
Die sind schön. Ich glaube, die nehmen wir für die Deko.
Hast du auch gleich gedacht, gell?
Und dann
schneide ich den einfach in Streifen
und der kommt später mit dazu.
Weil da will ich jetzt nicht, dass er so megaweich zerkocht.
Der kommt wirklich zum Schluss noch mit rein,
so die letzte halbe Stunde mit den Erbsen.
Das wird lecker!
[Musik]
Diesen harten Strunk in der Mitte nehme ich einfach raus.
So eine Riesenmenge, gell?
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Jetzt bereiten wir den
– das Brot zu.
Und zwar nehmt ihr jetzt einfach ganz viel Mehl.
Ich habe jetzt hier auch ein Dinkelmehl.
>> SAMIRA: Das ist wirklich viel Mehl.
>> SALLY: Ja. Denn der Teig, der ist ja wirklich ohne Kneten.
Der ist ganz, ganz flüssig.
Schön auf Mehl
ausschütten.
Und ihr seht jetzt hier auch richtig schön diese Teigstruktur.
Guckt mal,
wie die Hefe wunderschön aufgegangen ist.
Und aus dem Teig könnt ihr jetzt entweder Baguette formen,
also wenn ihr jetzt Baguettes machen möchtet,
– das ist ja auch wie jedes magische Baguette sozusagen –
oder ihr macht einfach ein Brot.
Wenn ihr Baguettes macht,
könnt ihr ein Baguetteblech benutzen
oder auch ganz einfach ein normales Backblech.
Also ihr braucht wirklich keine besonderen Dinge.
Stellt es dann in den Backofen bei 240°C
mit einem Schälchen Wasser am besten
wegen der Dampfbildung
oder im Dampfbackofen.
Ich mache jetzt aber ein Brot daraus.
Und ich habe jetzt hier zwar einen Dampfbackofen,
aber ich nutze jetzt einfach den Gusseisentopf
als Dampfbackofen.
Denn der
hat ja hier einen Deckel.
Und wenn der Deckel zu ist, dann kondensiert ja das Wasser
– dann verdampft das Wasser
und kondensiert hier an der Oberfläche
an diesen kleinen Noppen
und tropft wieder aufs Brot runter
und so bekommt ihr eine richtig schöne Kruste.
Also so machen wir es gleich.
Dann brauchen wir auch keinen Dampfofen dafür.
Ich halbiere es jetzt allerdings.
Ich mache zwei Brote daraus.
Und aus deiner Menge machen wir noch Minibrote, hä?
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
Also ich.
>> SALLY: Ja, das darfst du dann gleich machen.
Dann noch mal Mehl obendrauf,
auf die Hände auch.
Guck mal, von außen nach innen einfach so zusammenfassen.
Die Hände immer so ein bisschen bemehlen.
Und so in der Mitte
zusammenformen.
Dann ein bisschen Mehl auf den Boden des Topfes.
Und mit der Naht nach unten
einfach reinlegen.
[Musik]
Jetzt den Deckel drauf.
Dann stelle ich das in den kalten Backofen.
Denn der Backofen, der heizt ja auf
und die Aufheizzeit nutzt das Brot auch noch zum Aufgehen.
30 Minuten dann bei 200°C,
Deckel weg und dann noch mal 15 Minuten ungefähr.
Es kann auch sein 10 Minuten,
weil es jetzt ein bisschen kleiner ist.
>> SAMIRA: Oh, das zieht so schöne Fäden, gell?
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Mh.
Eins, zwei, drei.
Ich nehme die Mitte, die goldene Mitte.
Wir sollten öfter hier drehen.
Josh, ich sehe schon.
>> JOSH: Ja.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Sieht das gut aus oder sieht das gut aus?
Es sieht wunderbar aus.
Ich lasse es ganz kurz abkühlen
und dann nehme ich es aber raus
und gebe es dann hier direkt auf so ein Abkühlgitter.
Denn, wenn das Brot im Topf bleibt,
dann schwitzt es natürlich und wird wieder weich.
Und das wollen wir ja nicht.
Wir wollen ja ein schönes knuspriges Brot außen.
[Musik]
Ernsthaft?
Aber weißt du, was schön wäre?
In einer Glasschüssel.
Hol doch eine Glasschüssel.
Dann machen wir es ins Glas.
>> MURAT: Ja, ich finde das auch voll schön.
Mache ich.
>> SALLY: Eineinhalb Stunden sind jetzt vergangen.
Wow!
So sieht der Eintopf gerade aus.
Da müsst ihr echt immer dran denken:
Die Töpfe sind supersuperheiß!
Also ich habe jetzt mal den Rosmarinstängel entfernt.
Dann gebe ich jetzt die Erbsen rein.
Dann den Wirsing.
Ich denke, das sollte jetzt allein durch den Dampf
gut noch mal zurückgehen.
So. Und jetzt einfach noch mal
– ich würde es jetzt echt noch mal
für eine Stunde fast reingeben,
also dann insgesamt zweieinhalb Stunden.
Je länger, umso zarter ist das Fleisch.
[Musik]
Jetzt gibt es einmal Brot,
frisch geschnitten.
Murat, kannst du jedem dann gleich Bescheid geben?
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Oder magst du erst mal verkosten?
>> MURAT: Nee, lass mich
– pass auf, ich probiere erst mal
und wenn es mir schmeckt, dann rufe ich auch die anderen.
Okay?
>> SALLY: Okay.
Oh! Josh, guck mal hier.
[Musik]
Mittlerweile sieht es ja hier auch echt ganz anders aus,
muss man sagen.
Also Küche haben wir so gut wie fertig dekoriert.
Hier den Laden haben wir superschön dekoriert.
>> MURAT: O mein Gott! Das dazu.
>> SALLY: Ich habe es jetzt auch extra nicht mit Chili gewürzt,
denn ich habe mir ja gedacht, Murat, dass du deins...
>> MURAT: Guckt mal, das Chili-Olivenöl
einfach ein bisschen auf das Brot drauf.
>> SALLY: So zum Tunken?
Oder hier rein.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Oder hier mit rein.
Dann hast du es ja auch schärfer.
Also, wenn ihr ein bisschen Chili-Olivenöl drauf gebt,
habt ihr halt so einen Olivenöl- und Chiligeschmack.
Das ist echt schon
>> MURAT: Mmh!
>> SALLY: ziemlich gut, so ein bisschen Habanero.
>> MURAT: Kann ich einen Löffel haben?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SAMIRA: Ich glaube, ich probiere jetzt auch mal
vom Chili-Olivenöl.
>> SALLY: Ja, ich finde das nämlich auch mega.
>> MURAT: Oh, ich liebe das einfach!
So was richtig Warmes und Sättigendes.
>> SALLY: An so kalten Wintertagen.
>> MURAT: Ja, an kalten Wintertagen.
Kalt haben wir es nicht,
aber wir haben den ganzen Tag so viel gearbeitet
und alles aufgehängt.
>> SALLY: Mmh!
Aber es ist voll schön weich geworden jetzt.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SAMIRA: Ich habe Angst.
>> MURAT: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Und, Samira, Chili-Olivenöl?
>> SAMIRA: Warte.
>> MURAT: Oh!
>> SAMIRA: Scharf!
>> SALLY: Hm.
Gut, oder?
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SAMIRA: Scharf?
>> SALLY: Ich glaube, bei dir ist es heiß.
Bei dir ist es scharf.
>> MURAT: Bei mir ist es heiß.
>> SALLY: Also,
falls ihr das Rezept nachmachen möchtet,
dann könnt ihr es gerne nachlesen auf sallys-blog.de.
>> MURAT: Hammer! Schmeckt wirklich der Hammer!
>> SALLY: Wir machen jetzt hier noch fertig,
essen jetzt alle noch in Ruhe.
Danach gibt es noch Kinderpunsch für alle.
Hier noch vegan für Volkan.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und dann machen wir hier sauber
und morgen geht hier
die Weihnachtsbäckerei los.
>> MURAT: Genau.
Zweieinhalb Stunden hast du es drin gehabt, gell?
>> SALLY: Zweieinhalb Stunden.
>> MURAT: Also ihr könnt es auch wirklich mal
drei, vier, fünf, sechs Stunden drin lassen.
>> SALLY: Ja, das macht gar nichts.
>> MURAT: Das ist völlig egal. Wirklich!
>> SALLY: Das Gemüse wird halt immer weicher, aber...
>> MURAT: Aber zweieinhalb reicht vollkommen aus. Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja, zweieinhalb finde ich auch perfekt.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und da drin bleibt es ja auch jetzt schön warm.
Das heißt, dann kann man es ausmachen
und es ist immer noch
– in einer Stunde ist es auch noch warm.
>> MURAT: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Und ich würde es
– wenn ihr das Ganze an Weihnachten anrichtet,
finde ich es auch schön, wenn ihr die Minigusseisen nehmt,
die wir vorhin für die Brötchen genommen haben.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und wenn ihr die vorwärmt
und da dann das Gericht reinmacht,
dann bleibt das auch noch schön warm am Tisch.
>> MURAT: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Jetzt zeigen wir euch noch ein bisschen
den Laden, den fertig geschmückten,
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: und hoffen, dass wir euch bald hier sehen.
>> MURAT: Danke schön fürs Zuschauen!
>> SALLY: Danke euch!
Tschüss!
>> MURAT: Tschüss!
>> SALLY: Weißt du, was noch süß wäre?
Wenn wir irgendwo so einen Spot machen,
wo sich Menschen
– wie so einen Mistelzweig.
Weißt du? Wo sie sich drunterstellen
und so ein Foto machen können.
So voll romantisch.
So eins. Weißt du?
So.
>> MURAT: Mhm.
Mhm!
Mhm.
>> SALLY: So eins.
[Musik]